hello
oh can I lower this a little listen okay
okay
well just yeah no it's fine okay I'll
just get to it I'm so excited to be here
while brainstorming a list of the most
Farrell writers and academics with my
friend Ryan the two writers that
immediately came to mind were Bhanu
Kapil and Fred Mohan when Christina
Davis told me that the two would be
reading together my head basically
exploded to say I am honored to be
introducing Bhanu and Fred tonight would
be a gross understatement and I've been
going around telling people that this is
basically the highlight of my life
so Bhanu Kapil is an assistant professor
at Naropa's Jack Kerouac school of
disembodied poetics and a faculty member
at Goddard College's low residency
creative writing program she is is the
author of five full-length full-length
works the vertical interrogation of
strangers incubation a space for
monsters humanimal schizophrenia
ban and banlieue ban is a book about a
brown girl named bans encounter with a
race riot in London on April 23rd 1979
and Bhanu reminded me that tomorrow is
the anniversary the book was written
across 33 notebooks using a
compositional method that Bhanu
described to me yesterday as deletion
while we're reading ba news ban I woke
up thinking excess fat milk run off
blood in the gutter I was trying to
blurb the book and this is what I came
up with ban is she who cannot be written
directly she who must be written around
she who must be written in collaboration
with the dead the way teresa huck young
child's dead tongue licks the book yet
unwritten
the way bodily detritus becomes the meat
of the book ban is the placeholder as
book ban is all substitutions ban is the
shoutout as Jean rrah
ban is cut ban is all cut and the violet
light bursting out of the cut ban is the
leftover bacon grease ban as a blood
stain on the pavement Biblio man see a
brown girl on the floor of the world ban
is a wolf between the forest and the
city by way of a Gambon's banished when
I mailed Bhanu a chunk of menstral flesh
in an empty spice jar when she returned
my letter to show me it was covered in
my blood when she buried the glass pink
globules in the garden was this exchange
of flesh and blood writing is the act of
discarding itself writing ban is a trace
of what has been discarded ban is a
study of the transmogrification of body
into light when it is struck by a pink
lightning bolt ban is half dead and
escaping on the hide of a pink dolphin
ban is a freakish assemblage of
recombinant fragments ban is the view
from the ground from beneath the ground
ban is disgusting ban is a research
topic that does not get funded because
there is an there is no point from which
it can be analyzed ban is not a public
history it is the history of racism that
cannot be told for ban has been mutated
by a form of racism that does not
register because it circulates as
radiation ban is beneath the event of
the race riot
she is the ground on which the race riot
takes place ban is covered in broken
glass I still don't know what ban is I
know that bonnie's figures are the
immigrant the monster
and the schizophrenic like Banu I also
believe that notebook roulette can be a
method by which one generates a book our
second reader tonight is Fred Mohan Fred
is a poet scholar poet and scholar
working across the disciplines of
performance studies and black studies he
is a professor of English at UC
Riverside and is the author of in the
break the aesthetics of the black
radical tradition
Houston's tavern B Jenkins the field
trio a National Book Award finalist the
little edges and co-author with Stefano
Harney who is also here in the audience
of the undercommons fugitive planning
and black study in in the break the
aesthetics of the black radical
tradition fred takes us on a meandering
journey through a series of associative
lyrical and philosophical meditations on
everything from value theory to James
Brown in the introduction alone we
encounter imaginative readings of Karl
Marx and Frederick Douglass
dense theorization of the relationship
between sound and materiality and
interventions into conceptions of
subjectivity and continental philosophy
while some find Fred's work difficult to
understand as a poet I am wholeheartedly
in favor of Fred's Fugitive style fred
is interested in that which is in that
which escapes that which exhausts
meaning and description if the lines and
sentences of his poetry and scholarship
always seemed to be running away it's
because fred is enacting a politics of
elusive 'ti much like the insurgent
subjects he celebrates in his texts
whether he's writing about his mother B
Jenkins or the pianist Cecil Taylor Fred
embraces the fugitive because he
believes
that that which cannot be regulated
cannot be contained in the opening of
the title poem of Fred's collection B
Jenkins Fred writes about two themes
that appear throughout his work
insurgent black social life and the
party as an improvised and celebratory
mode of social organization in the poem
B Jenkins the home of his mother is a
place where people gather and conspire
wherein the words of James Brown the
long-haired hippies and afro blacks
danced between break and secret but
their clandestine party is always in
relation to that which it is held by the
cell that attempts to hem in black
social life the Bleak architecture of
the multiplex and the regular highway in
every two-tone station in the poem
however these oppressive containers are
rent open and become the subterranean
party's condition of possibility
Fred celebrates the party as a form of
life because the party is mobile because
the party is fugitive it is a social
experiment and under common activity
that is not regulated by any former
rules or strictures as Fred and Stefano
Harney right and the undercommons quote
the plan is to invent the means in a
common experiment launched from any
kitchen any back porch any basement any
hall any park bench any improvised party
every night
end quote to plan is not to control how
and where people come together but to
invent new experiments that enable
people to live their lives in common
please join me in welcoming Bhanu Kapil
and Fred Mohan
good evening my name is
vaanu Kapil and I have quarantined
myself behind this white tablecloth
because I can only see the very tips of
your noses but I greet you I greet you
which is to say thank you Christina
and Jackie and Fred for being here and
Jackie and Christina in particular not
to mention Mary and everyone else I met
in the last 35 minutes but thank you in
particular Jackie for allowing me to
elaborate a new experiment of some kind
one that I hope will involve the bodily
detritus that you mentioned earlier an
experiment that began at 7:00 p.m. last
night in your kitchen so that is my
dream that I can present a kitchen
experiment tonight but also I must
mention the ocean and the fact that
every single reading but I've given this
spring from my book I have deleted it is
very unfortunate and I'm quite
determined not to do the same tonight so
I do have a little plan of what I want
to read however some of my work is
fiction and some of it is something that
resembles the poetry of the great Swan
on the River Thames you know the one the
one with the dirty beak and city
feathers the grimy Swan and there wasn't
sure how to read from both sections of
the book so I thought simply because I
calculated that it's almost 7 p.m. am i
correct is it almost 7 p.m. what time
says 6:20 okay so in 40 minutes is April
the 23rd 1979 in the United Kingdom
which is to say it is April the 23rd
2015 which is to say it is April the
23rd 1970
which is the night but I unfold in my
book and so I thought I would begin by
bringing a little bit of that
neighborhood scene and link it to the
vibration of this quite frankly so
beautiful duck egg blue chandelier
typesetting but I never imagined I could
ever be in in my whole life
I lived next door to a very naughty boy
called Steven Whitby he was a member of
the National Front Youth League he had a
shaved head
he had boots that he tightly laced to
his knee he was a terrible child the
only person he was scared of was my
father which perhaps gives you some idea
of how frightening my own father was
every morning Steven Whitby would wake
up and go to the doorsteps of our
Gujarati and Kenyan neighbors and empty
the milk bottles that arrived very early
upon their doorsteps they were covered
with red foil for the extra cream and
silver foil for the low fat and he would
empty the milk from these milk bottles
very carefully peeling off the foil into
the grass of their front gardens and
then he would refill those bottles with
what I have to say was a rather copious
amount of urine what was he thinking
that KUB Lee's mother would grab the
milk bottle of urine from the doorstep
and pour it over her cornflakes question
mark or perhaps that she would add a
dash of it a slug to the boiling chai
spices and parboiled Darjeeling leaves
I don't know but to that end I have
brought some milk and I have brought
some urine I'm just going to roll up my
sleeves
and if you'd like to stand up for the
next one and a half minutes you are
quite welcome to
that did not work please sit down this
is the milk and this is the urine
delicious and now I can begin meat
forest in 1979 ban fulfills the first
criteria of monstrosity simply by
degrading by omitting bars of light from
her teeth and mouth when the rain sweeps
over her band back again I like how the
rain is indigo like a tint that reveals
the disease process in its inception
above her the pink lightning is branched
forked in five places a brown ankle
sparkles on the ground genital life
gives way to bubbles The Notebook of a
body's two eyes like a person in an
ancient pose I lean in an l-shape
posture over the counter flat back
rump displayed to any passerby blood
dripping down the backs of my thighs
they don't see me I clean the street
until all that's left is a ring of oily
foam the formal barrier of a bad snow
are you sick and tired of running away
then lie down invert yourself above a
ditch or stream beneath the bright blue
sky then pull yourself up from your
knees to clean clean the street until
all that's left is a ring of oily foam
the formal barrier of a bad snow it
snows that April for a few minutes early
in the day children walking on the
Southall Broadway open their mouths to
receive the aluminium snowflakes in
their bright pink and chocolate brown
dresses tucked beneath the heavy blue
coats these immigrant children are
dazzled by the snow even though they
were born here a train ride from a city
tilted to receive the light it's sprig
bending over in the window of the pretty
Bank many years later I returned to
place a daffodil on the Uxbridge Road is
zink an element it's a sheen spread it
on the ankle of ban is there a copper
wire is there a groin make a mask for
ban what is ban an is a mixture of dog
and bitumen ash scraped up the
soles of running shoes
Puma Reebok adidas looping the city ban
is a walk of smoke to summarise she is
the parts of something remixed as air
integral rigid air circa 1972 to 1979
she's a girl a black girl in an era when
in solidarity caribbean and asian brits
self defined as black a black brown girl
encountered in the earliest hour of a
race riot or what will become one by
nightfall April the 23rd 1979 by morning
anti-nazi campaigner Blair peach will be
dead it is in this sense a real day
though ban is unreal she's both dead and
never living the part that is of life
that is never given an existence what
for example is born in England but is
never not even on a cloudy day
English answer ban under what conditions
is a birth not recognised as a birth and
from ban Banja the former hunting
grounds of King Henry the 8th earth
mounds Oaks split into several parts by
a late century lightning storm these
suburbs are in places leafy and
industrial the Nestle factory spools a
milky lilac effluent into the Grand
Union canal that runs between Hayes and
alfe all banners nine banners seven
banners ten banners a girl walking home
from school just as a protest starts to
escalate pausing at the corner of the
UPS bridge road she hears something the
far-off sound of breaking glass is it
coming from her home or is it coming
from the streets distant clamor faced
with these two sources of a sound she
instinctively links to violence the
potential of violent acts ban lies down
she falls to the ground
this is syntax psychotic faecal neural
wild the auto sacrifice begins in doors
the night never stops goes on as even
more time passes as the image or
instinct to form this image desiccates I
pop a mirror than another on the ground
for ban a cyclical and artificial light
falls upon her in turn pink gold amber
then pink again do the mirrors deflect
evil perhaps they protect her from a
hoard of boys with shaved heads or
perhaps they illuminate in strings of
weak light the part of the scene when
these boys finally arrive the left hand
covered in a light blue ash the ash is
analgesic data suit though when it rains
a band becomes leucine a bulk and
network of dirty lines that channel
starlight presents boots someone walks
towards her for example then around her
then away I want to lie down in the
place I am from on the street I am from
in the rain next to the ivy as I did on
the border of Pakistan and India the two
Punjab's nobody sees someone do this I
want to feel it in my body the root
cause Cobra notes for ban
I want a literature that is not made
from literature a girl walks home in the
first moments of a race right before it
might even be called that the sound of
breaking glass as equidistant as
happening coming from the street and
from her home
what loops the ivy asphalt glass girl
combinations abraded as it goes I think
two of the curved passing sound that has
no fixed source in a literature what
would happen to the girl I write instead
the increment of her failure to orient
to take another step and understand she
is collapsing to her knees then to her
side in a sovereign position notes for
ban 2012 a year of sacrifice and rupture
murderous roses blossoming in the
gardens of immigrant families with money
problems citizens with a stash and so on
eat Appel and die die if you have to see
and gate serpent gate hole I myself
swivel around and Crouch at the
slightest unexpected sound when she
turned her face to the Ivy I saw a cube
of foil propped beneath the vines
posture made a circuit from the ivy to
her face the london street a tiny jungle
dark blue slick and shimmering a bit
from the gold brown tights she was
wearing beneath her skirt a girl stops
walking and lies down in the street in
the opening scene of a riot why at
points it rains in the novel that no one
writes or thinks of writing the rain
falls in lines and dots upon her in the
loose genetics of what makes this street
real the freezing cold vibrating weather
sweeping through southeast England at 4
p.m. on an April afternoon is very
painful
sometimes there is a day and sometimes
there is a day reduced to its symbolic
elements a cup of broken glass
the Queen's portrait on the thin bronze
coin dosage rain this is why a raindrop
indents the concrete with atomic
intensity this is why the dark green
glossy leaves of the ivy are so green
multiple kinds of green as night falls
on the skirt the outskirts of London lay
bonheur
ban on Bon dia suburban a puff of diesel
fumes on an orbital road the country
outside London with its old parks and
labyrinths of rhododendron and azalea
futile and tropical pinks in a
near-constant downpour of green black
and silver rain in the forest outside
London a light ice falls through the
trees like a glitter a snake Aspen
coloured bright yellow with green
stripes slips through the bracken its
pink eyes open and black diamond-shaped
irises blinking on then off in frozen
time ancient beings emerge with the
force of reptiles in the forest time and
weather are so mixed up a trope of
bedtime stories bottom-up processing
need I need the snake to stop the news
this is the news a girl's body is
dressed and set still yet trembling upon
a rise in the forest there are stars now
it's night time is coming on hard the
snake slips over her leg her brown ankle
she's wearing shoes
maroon patent leather shoes with a low
heel and 3 slim buckles but no socks
whoever dressed her was in a hurry
imagine the scene a forest outside
London 7 p.m. an April snowfall the
ground still coppery gold a snake has
escaped from time a water box a shelf
volatile starving its senses a parallel
self the girl's body emitting a solar
heat absorbed in the course of a
lifetime
but now discharging pushing off without
thought below thought it moves towards
her through the rusted trees inversions
4 ban
to ban someone is to say that no one may
harm him a Gambon a monstrous hybrid of
human and animal divided between the
forest and the city ban to be banned
from the city and thus on banja a part
of the perimeter in this sense to study
the place where the city dissolves is to
study the wolf is this why some of my
best friends have come from the
peninsula of Long Island to ban to
sentence to abandon is thus to write
prose already dared nude a wolf's head
upon a form the form is the body in the
most generic way I could possibly use
that word the nude body spills color
blue nude green nude the nudes of
prehistory in a pool of chalk in an
urgent bar cave a Gambon's thought
familiar to me already from the exchange
of Arjun and Christian on the
battlefield
I should stop writing now what did a
wolf and the schizophrenic have in
common here extreme snow I mean fire the
extreme snow makes me neutral about this
first
intact fragment of ban a novel of the
race riot ban nude studies charcoal
marks wired to the mouth of a pig a boar
some of the work is set in the outlying
wooded regions of Greater London where
King Henry the Eighth had his hunting
grounds as a girl I would lie down in my
coat and trousers in the snow upon an
embankment of Earth engineered centuries
before to keep the meat in I wanted to
write a book that was like lying down
that took some time to write but kept
forgetting something that took a
diversion from which it never returned I
wanted to write a book on the butcher's
table in New Delhi the shop front opened
to the street a bare light bulb swinging
about the table and next
to where a book swinging from that cook
in the window I wanted to write a book
inverted corrupted exposed to view a
person writes a book in their free time
calling that time what they want to call
that I wanted to write a book about
England I wanted to write a book about
lying on the floor of England I wanted
to return to England I went to England I
was born in England I lived in our house
in England until I was thirty years old
my parents were English I was English
after 1984 we all shared the same
nationality but by 2006 or 2007 this was
no longer true between September 2010
and late December 2012 I studied a piece
of the earth no longer or wider than a
girl's body prone upon it the asphalt as
dusk fell violet amber and filled with
reflected lights coming down from the
disks the tiny mirrors positioned in the
ivy as she slept on a balcony or Street
the asphalt's green stars the shed parts
of a ragged elm comes spring ban is a
portal of vortex a curl a mixture of
clockwise and anti-clockwise movements
in the sky above the street I study the
vapor as it rises accumulates then
starts to move how a brisk wind
organizes the suit or casings and bits
of bark into walls in grand finale
number nine notes for a novel never
written and this is for Jackie Wang
excuse me I'm quite dehydrated
excuse me man dreams of being eaten
alive by wolves van has tickets from the
West End and playbills that will surely
be worth something someday are those two
words someday tucked into a suitcase or
sent in a crate this pure banality the
sending of household supplies by freight
is an emigrant Act a form of nudity and
not a novel length account notes with
some anger the kind that builds up over
years in the absence of social services
I write sentences for days day three day
four day nine days you never see
chucking back your Bombay Sapphire gin
on the patio define patio you could be
naked out back and no one would see
nobody were the two vowels whose
generosity or displayer
just as the body without clothes is
analogous to erase mark I asked my
nine-year-old son why he wore his
t-shirt to the outdoor pool he said mom
I think there might be some racists here
I wanted to tell him honey honey
ban is lying in the dirt all sticky from
her eyes ban is alone in the cafe as an
adult dispersing the gazes of others
with nothing more than a pen and a cup
of coffee she's in India always India
where cafe culture varies region by
region to be almost non-existent in the
part she is from where she is in a
sector 17 cafe writing in a place where
everyone else is eating a quick
breakfast like a tourist or office
worker or the boss taking his time and
even smoking smoking a rolled-up
cigarette as he drinks his chai
staring hard at ban when she stops
writing yes ma'am
called coffee ban licks the foam of her
spoon then bends her head to the page
again but what is she writing in my own
way from this wet perch one foot chained
to the cage I am staring to a parrot a
shabby vivid bird pecking at her words
in times of great freedom when the
writing comes I fly back to my own
writing with what she knows this is
another reason not to write novels or
read to summarize I don't want to have
sex ever again in my life
I don't want to if it means partnering
with a white man a man who takes your
polka-dotted dress from you and puts it
on or leaves it on the brown plastic
tray with the remnants of breakfast
outside the door for a late morning
cleanup why in fact would anyone disrobe
with such casual proficiency then lie
down like that with their legs and arms
in the air like a baby why would a
person get naked for a person with whom
you do not share culture ban I don't
want it but if fan is a fundamentalist
if ban converts at some point to the
radical ideal of the body as somehow
untouchable the very thing you cannot
reach then at some point she'll have to
take off her kit sometimes I see ban in
the dirt of the place she is from ban
lying down on a sidewalk in London
without resistance
beneath the Ivy at night like bones
before they are bones like eyes in the
time that follows talking thank you that
as the end of my fake novel
Wow that was I don't know what to say I
mean thank you for being here
Thank You Jackie Christina Mary thank
you Bob what I have to offer is quite
paltry I guess some well what I thought
about was reading a few poems from our
few pieces from the last section of the
field trio which is called I ran from it
but was still leaning and and then I
read a little bit from the little edges
and then some new stuff the I ran from
me but was still in it my um my
next-door neighbor went a few years ago
in Los Angeles a good friend of mine
named John Moore and John his uncle
passed away and I went to the funeral
and the preacher was doing it kind of
you know more or less typical kind of
black genereal thing in which he talked
a little bit in his eulogy about John's
uncle but spend most of the time really
making a kind of plea for conversion in
the way that it works was that you know
John's uncle never had anything didn't
anything to worry about now and the
question was whether or not everybody
else in the room had taken their
insurance out
and he described this feeling of being
uninsured as being somewhat like what it
must have been what if he what he
described as would it be what it was
like to be inherit Hurricane Katrina and
he said that the storm was so big that
he ran from it but was still in it and
and I used to think I still think that
that that was a perfect way to describe
what people used to call thought
although they don't call it that much
anymore the black experience in America
and so what I wanted to do in these
poems was to see what it was like to run
from something while you were still in
it
so there made eleven blind poems kind of
very much shaped like a box or like a
cell and all of them begin with I which
is meant in a way both to invoke you
know a certain set of lyrical
conventions but also meant to invoke
something that bono says and
schizophrenia that I don't exist anyway
so I'm going to read the last few poems
from there I often amount to no more
than a stylistics Aryan love an
uncountable song and I want to amount to
nothing more than that my gift is more
than you can carry all other things are
just my style my thing is everything is
everything and there's nothing more than
my bouquet my uncountable thing outside
my voice is inside blow up inside a
blackening gift from a broken hand
we were cagey in our bib caps and our
overcoats carry the hidden weight of our
broken circle lost city people make the
world go round
remember that time at the Marion Wardman
Park
I carry the particles from market to
market
I can't lose with this stuff I use my
essence presses lightly down on
presencing the in complete victory sound
like enough to me but still in all it's
real heavy to sing with broken records
to get hooked up to a free response
to mythically lift your hand differently
as rhythmically as everything to take a
little break and lead your Arkansas and
still fold it in your own marking song
and the broke distillery it Cummins to
carry over the lost mass inside but open
I'll always be the thing presenting
broken Jam particles I come from the
city of markers I'd like to put a
surprise in your lunchbox just for you I
know you'll know the resonator and a
good strong piece of pepper man and how
that go all the way back to Lake Mead
and Engelstad you can put moves inside
little bits of colored paper and put it
in a chest for all their friends to open
up and not remember say a little prayer
for you as a love song from mother to
son and that's cool and you know that if
I hold my hand on my cheek when I
breathe her name that's like a piece of
hard candy in your lunchbox and your
cell block I'd like to be able to give
you these things from time to time I
circulate babylon and translate for the
new times secret runaway ads brush and
cruise each other and the project run
away in the Brocade and panache of
intuitions and they're bracketed
patterns we wait to boom their hands
poised chiffon and counteract red fleece
their petal is a stone a pedra flying
down a red top with a blue scarf flying
this is all limited by mamas black beads
one give him come up and sew on the
bottom lip between Atlin and that one
that rubbed that
thread a uniform of tongue to blemishes
and star frets on sideways my old guitar
just loved to sing I can't love nobody
but the poor misunderstanding pan tuning
is our luxury we need a little own mint
on the edge our mannered labor we're the
workout that the people always gather
when they play mas even if nobody wants
to be out here but you it's okay when
you sing what you don't know how to say
the same terms we buried all of them on
less than that we turned away from the
grave and fell out and now you've got
the only one to know who Lucille is
didn't know where Lucille is that have
no place to go that sometimes we just
turn and brush our hands because I'd
like to enjoy myself
I enjoyed you Fred because we tell
stories because we live in common every
night live in Stockholm the secret
acceleration of a thousand years on the
road till the particles collide and cry
on the bridge between CERN and Fermilab
as sacred means the theory of enjoyment
is in repose rubbing the history of
broken veins and tiles wore down the
velvet the theory of enjoyment puts
itself in danger to remain still as a
part of breath while the sails glide
when you can't do no better the feeling
of the theory of enjoyment is solid the
experiment of the ones who live to eat
enormous Lee I am foment I speak bling
wish it worked they called me but I
don't come I come and she called me by
my rightful name I come to myself from
far away just lay back in the open I ran
from it and was still in it it's a blue
division on my goodbye window I'm full
of outer space I'm free is dread all
night I get clung with a voice that gets
held back by
protection I'm daddy I come with he
crazy he called me I'm crazy I come when
he call me once upon a time in Arkansas
when the water come I come to the
unprotected surge and division in my old
new sound booth
I am FM oh my read umm I'm gonna read
some stuff from just one section from
the little edges so basically this is a
kind of thing that I wrote for this kind
of conversation that was put on at the
Museum of Modern Art and it was
organized by Ralph lemon and it's called
hard enough to enjoy Ralph lemon was
born in Cincinnati Ohio clean records
infant archivist and rhythmic on his
contributions to the theory of gravity a
flown crawled choreograph of attractions
breathing the variously collided
particles of Isley Colin's wild there
Troutman Fleetwood and all the
ungenerous returner players of Southwest
Ohio are crucial to that terrible arc of
funk in flesh of which impossible
mothers speak with electromagnetic slide
later charged with the blackness of
physics it's extra legal social sea
realities in search of conceptual
thought having survived the rivers
violent flows and squalls
it's seizing distancing but drawn to the
river of rivers of rivers lemon began a
long series of residences in itinerants
his efforts filed under vanishing and
binding disappear in the world's most
important collections and divisions our
clearing is patrolled as a series of air
spirals in conjunction made by pointed
running it was affirmation where we
learn how to talk by walking pointedly
to organize
err off stride by tapping like a lion my
touch my mouth are fixed to say these
words by listening in winter
my mirror glancing big eyed cartoon all
this in there as an audible surface that
my eye wants to help you think about as
you feel me feel me that's why I always
ask you if you feel me because I know
you feel me I ask you if you feel me
because I know you feel me another
alignment of questions and I could be
having a coke with you I could be riding
around with you like elements in an open
field
spinning in ourselves till our supports
collapse into a choir a battery of iron
on the floor a pallet on the floor a
plywood blanket for some intimate unrest
all these layers of not returning to
before and before here come here come
here come our flowers made of crystal
encrusted syrup our seasoning is ham
bone and our self-abuse our swirling
coattails enchant array big leg cartoon
perform our box of wonders from the book
of wonder this order winds its way
around the hills out from Oxford
everybody fell in love with everybody
hollering everybody waiting on everybody
whining everybody tapping and wobbling
the kettle whining everybody's
struggling to play everybody's straying
while everybody come and go we couldn't
wait for Labor Day and all his bright
ash fusillade and savour we couldn't
wait without remembering them buried all
together full of shoddy Thomas echoing
and leading winding at the head of our
wailing Abbey's forming with pleasure
and abandoned tearing tasting and
abandonment and stepping and studying
why we came going nowhere going
everywhere here come marching this
burled expansive welcome homelessness
sound like marching
here come here come last time I said and
waited for you to leave and I gonna see
you no more how can you stay the
southern question of travel makes a
joyful noise and moves slowly in
awareness now we can speculate on the
relay of our common activity make a
circle around our errant routes dancing
is what we make of falling music is what
we make of musics absence the real
presence making music underneath I'm
exhausted so my soul is rested
Ralph lemon was born in alternative
Mississippi like many alternatives of
Mississippi he was schooled in a chain
of monastic launchpads reading under
conceptual repair making arrangements
and the theory of repercussions in
repose in the experiment set at an angle
just a pause and while a sitting in a
rocking just posed against standing
still inclined to engage in forensic
study of the auction block of ideas and
its stained wood but open also to her
echo his efflorescence nothing what else
can you expect from corrosion in bloom
corrosion in bloom is all you can expect
all you can expect is everything it's
hard enough to enjoy
I read um I read a couple I read one
thing sometimes you get in a habit of
like not reading stuff and uh I don't
know why but anyway I like this one I
never read I don't know why but I'm
gonna read it now it's called test and
and there's a couple of epigraphs a
small and still isolated incident in New
York shows what can happen if authentic
Authority and social relations has
broken down to the point where
cannot work any longer even in its
derivative purely functional form a
minor mishap in the subway system the
doors on a train failed to operate
turned into a serious shutdown on the
line lasting for hours and involving
more than 50,000 passengers because when
the transit authorities asked the
passengers to leave the defective train
they simply refused that's from our
non-violence the second epigraph more
than 50,000 subway riders were stranded
in the tunnels of the IRT 7th Avenue
Line last night after passengers on a
defective train at one hundred and tenth
Street refused to leave as instructed by
Transit Authority employees according to
the Transit Authority the trouble began
shortly after 5:30 p.m. when the doors
on a northbound train failed to operate
correctly at hundred and tenth Street in
Lenox Avenue one man said he had strayed
in the tunnel directing others to the
exits at one-hundred and third Street
I acted as though I knew what I was
doing he said because people usually
believe you when you do that's from a
story by Robert McFadden in the New York
Times January 4th 1969 this is how we
never arrived in fuse what we surround
to not remember every day we cross from
slave state to slave state in the
Barrett cars we pass by to avoid
examination in the Sun we were dark to
ourselves when That Bird started
whistling in the tunnel making music we
were made to follow fail to legislate
wouldn't get off got off so hard we got
off everywhere our breathing empties the
air with fullness and we're in love in a
state of constant sorrow the outcome is
another process a way into no way the
refuge is open and can't be safe the
mobile engineer puts some alternate
Dutchman pressure on F train stand for
whoever will ride
the private investors inability to
afford himself is more and more clear as
a general costliness m2 just gone
wherever they want to people need to get
to church and it's a bike tool you can't
drink that store-bought coffee from a
flying saucer
the Animus Sheen is Henry Dumas stopping
bullets wide interval woody Shaw flying
transfers almost all the way to mermaid
the newly born instrument is a whole
bunch of differences your refusal ain't
sustainable it just can't sustain itself
you do what they say till you die like a
dog too much stress on the impossible
one we stressed this past the point to
bring the history of getting down
experimental slant can't help but hurt
you look how hard and sharp it makes you
breathe you have to refuse in real time
with things that revised in real time
when the wind is closed there's some
ways not to love refreshment but they
are up we quiver with work and
revival we carry ourselves to you ready
to hear what that sound like across 110
Street is a hell of a tester the
blackness of the witty partition be hand
to mouth to hand in the subway out of
breath is an air shaft under a rent
party the rent party is the curriculum
of the rent party department the
department was so outlandish and
groundless that she was arrogant for
calls stiff up in the face of the
unadmitted as they exist on paper in
donation in contempt of their training
though a citizen of Riverside just up
from Hamsterdam might not want to try to
understand charisma like Kenneth Warren
she didn't know what african-american
literature was Sol courses in marburg or
an expensive spirit in a waste of shame
Ceylan was solo unadmitted an ecology of
the supplement department the burnt
fringe of speakers lock open strata
bottom and jug off centering everything
every
every trumpet was deported by her voice
which was never more than enough from
holding her breath on Riverside where
you can still feel the burn of the
eastern question Eastern man alone in
her caress feigning rub study in the
desert in the Church of unnatural
there's a riot going on and all for the
making of black revolutionary stone on
stone sorry some new stuff this is a I
don't know what I think it might be a
book in it I keep changing the name and
my first thoughts gonna call it recess
then I was gonna call it blue key school
I was gonna I knew I couldn't call it
boogie school cos it's just like only so
much stuff I could steal from Nate
Mackie you know it's like you know he's
getting embarrassed about it now so but
now I think I might start calling it a
Collura Chur maybe we'll see but um
we'll see I got a few things this is
called ooh but it could be Oh
groove conjecture in ruthless happiness
ohoooo absence in contusion rehearse and
strain in the new colonial rubble
sufficient for grounding refusal and
Plaza real grammar is weed ecology out
burning about building a bloom surround
a picture of nothing but surrounding
there she go the essence of it is way
outside multiple scenes for exhausting
the pure multiple speech of impure
release center thighs and a computable
flex through past and future Big Momma's
Anna recombinant anima be impossible to
dress nothing like no makeup for the
more plus less than ones had been
reduced to a target of him making
himself up faking himself hold pushing
wholeness on the hold still riding old
paint still riding old paint stop riding
old paint goodbye old paint
I'm leaving Cheyenne we emerge in the
wide border where Alton and Hortons
persistence emulation moved
boogie-woogie
munos Dougal Booga boom bridged
exclamation self-stimming itself away up
under all that surfacing four scratch
surfaces the surfer tree of our
raggedy-ass circuitry till we all decide
to improve what's in the jet plus in de
jet in the dragon can't expect how math
go groove then amor its notion can't
send understand we a message when we owe
to hear our doing my black forest what
it is with the real groove rolling
through the burial and deep frying of my
hammer and horn he goes some lip
smacking swine in a black spear it's an
a positional quickness we stuck on the
first six books taste good and you pay
out when you become an observer when you
make your observations on being an
observer when your ruler
so we detonate enchant and dredge the
see if I ever even try to stop singing
this you can eat my heart till then I'll
be trying to kill you every day I say
this not to you as if you were there or
you but to the house band this head just
stay in the air we must be our own dream
huh miss Jackson I will be so quiet when
I stole into the kitchen to get my
cookie what you said was mine without
ever saying so you could dream about me
doing it again and again while falling
still falling your air just out of reach
all information blown away all that
fabric inside the gravity of all that
free love I have a really good friend
named Arthur J flex a great filmmaker
and he uh he's a great filmmaker and
he's got these amazing ideas for like
big huge films you know but he's too
good for these ideas to ever give me you
know and however many 5060 million
dollars it would take or 100 million
dollars and he's never probably never
gonna get the money unless one of us
hits the lottery but and part of the
reason that he'll never be able to make
these films because he has ideas like
this he called me on the phone and I
said yeah man I want you to write a
voiceover for me he said I want you to
write something in the character or one
of Michael Vick's his dogs
so I'm like okay man
I shouldn't be enable him in this kind
of stuff right because you know make it
probably but it's okay he's actually
made amazing films he was a
cinematographer of daughters of the dust
and it just made recently this great
documentary called dreams are colder
than death and he's he's brilliant but
anyway this is called Michael Dahl but I
feel in my eye and the bruise blood
beneath Beneatha's maximal breath I'm
British Brack British bend but I just
can't live there from there but see me
in fresh text Lehrer not lots Lita not
Lehrer the phase is the phase for show
show to come out to show them I love
them big pots with bubbles behind like a
seam seen my doggy no dog and my dog in
my dog with my bitch singing backup at
Sunday school she back up her buzz and
her dry windy beat beat but drifted in
permanent curl I'm scary you know what
it feel like to ask if I'm for this did
all this leave our mics alone make me is
up under that same another thing oh
feely is the chapel blue ride cereal
blur Vista bruise blood blues recessive
natural blue be down here on the ground
can't share but Shulkin style but show
can scan the monkey live here you Vista
miss sorption we've been gone here
Tom's they've been upstairs in the water
every Saturday night recess is flat-out
jump sweet bliss is stress no pressure a
rhythm fish his fresh on the porch
gravity and air pass
portraiture falling apart is little New
Orleans how long can we say how long
we've been here how long can foxy curl
coming and going as a grain called
stress and we drink to that
bliss is secretly chocolate people slow
down when they come pass here other
is hard traffic pressure in Santa Monica
and you if you don't take care out here
you ever written something you
embarrassed about
so I I ain't gonna ever be
embarrassed again yeah but I'm uh this
is my condition my condition my
condition chronic musical condition
dystonia smear homunculus disorganized
clust kitchi kitchi yaya ya gitchy
gitchy Yaya here kissed logic board
breakfasted kojic tongue can't fall for
dancing wonder how much sleep when she's
saying that at the White House
White House be glued lyrics selfie
suck my dick hallelujah I
love you so
that's who come up on the curlicue at
stealing vocation transpire informal and
blunt community Hugh should be rough
you'd be round like Hugh sink or his
sister and she pray like a tree we guess
we planted as we be blue as we can be
fade and flow just and after a while but
we endlessly accrue onvo kalian toe up
we up in there just cuz you feel good up
in here there's a divinity that we'd be
cleaving to like Ghost Dog
young lord of the general swore we the
general Hugh Ponte physics the universal
machine is a bridge that conditionally
branches that's the conditional bridges
a family tree for the birds in an
abolition of quilting and I don't know
whether to Pat my foot inside the shoe
or to Pat the whole shoe but it's cool
when you cause that cozy cold condition
and I don't know whether to say it with
my feet or with my hands the thing about
the other man and his crappie market his
honey coldest thing and all that showing
new arethe is in the mixing on the phone
on the question of life and contra
session in new a V Airy mixing the
universal machine requires a mechanics
of flesh so the quantum anomalies can be
followed that's what will always be
inseparable with whoo for he'll all by
Holland a rule of staggered missives and
committed to the non exclusion of birds
our model for remote intimacy in ritual
is missile this our near-miss our
distant feel communicable mystery be
folded in the arms of our best regards
throw our beautifully imagine children
nearly miss each other since we meant
each other cornered each other off
square cube failed plaza come circle
inside sound tree
in every shade of green ain't nothing
going on welcome over here over share
overcome Parliament as intercontinental
birds and that that little bit of that
poem was was was kind of dedicated to
this architect named Sandy Hill ah
who works with a group called design our
kids art architecture residency they
wrote this really great book they're
based in Bethlehem and they wrote this
really amazing book called architecture
after revolution that I've been obsessed
with and and I'm gonna read just one
more I think that's also dedicated to
her and that has a kind of sung epigraph
and then a an epigraph that comes from a
section of the book that she wrote so
excuse my singing this is called
supposing al Masha a mash-up exposing I
should fall in love with you do you
think that you could love me to expose
and I should hold you and caress you
would it impress you or distress you
supposing I should say for you I yearn
would you think I'm speaking out of turn
and supposing I declare it would you
take my love and share it
I'm not supposing I'm in love with you
sandy recalled the time of the First
Intifada when people in Beit Sahour
refused to pay taxes to the colonial
authorities a revolt known as the white
into father
one night the army entered my house and
confiscated furniture the television
phones and among other things my
precious little radio transmitter
goosh Grob at the time was used as a
prison but also as a storage for
confiscated goods entering the base 20
years later I thought I might find my
radio suppose we don't take place our
thing would be sub positional and we'd
have to keep falling in love with that
we'd have to assume the opposition let
it turn
let's turn let's turn it out let's go
out of turn and speak out from there
suppose we'd arranged suppose Diadema is
sassy suppose the intensity of the
erotic relationship between Socrates and
Roz off we're giving it to do by those
who claim to be concerned with virtue
our pursuit is a rich braid of
indirection this plaited movement in
stillness we're theme variation and
Restatement of theme turn out to have
been coterminous is where difficulty and
pleasure meet in their essence as
practice established as a strain and
striation of questioning suppose we
don't take place they tell us all we
need to know by curving that track they
keep laying down trainers garland and
open secret chambers in the rimshot city
of erotic Brotherhood for miles and
miles and miles
but then there's what we need to know in
order to get to that going through and
getting past and running around like
riding the blinds of our Hitler's Teresa
and croon the social situation of
philosophy is slavery but the
Underground stroll of black and blue
Garvey i'ts
is our hyperspatial mu temporal line
suppose we take no place that's how we
listen and revolve reclining as we eat
one another softly cut while we serve
one another mixed up in the general need
till symposium explodes antagonized
unsettled in the practicums repose
because we're up under its protection
preoccupy with how we sing and vestibule
assembled in common thicknesses the anti
state and anti state of nature our
geographic swerve in varying sharpness
--is of drafting and over drafting of
profanation all speculation drawing
parabolic fuse and
furled refusal Earth's algorithmic
dancehall air thin sliver in the after
morning when the nation is no longer
mourned the given given in the cleaning
of the square in care of line in no
man's land and worried bridge plain
unmeasured hain't and brush and verb and
pleat and re and D not see but out
that's how we sing for birds we guess we
grew suppose we take no place an echo
haunts the house of every family we
visit through the holes and held up in
the air we breathe our camp is circular
but fugue and just that little radio
they grab is our cohabitated walk-in
near haunt for the general mash up the
regenerative and degenerative our Masha
in cultivation of calendars perk public
garden turn and would you take my love
and share it suppose Sandy Hill all be
listening disposing